Timm Legler set to join us legs a former
NBA three-point shooting champ and a
tenure NBA veteran he'll be one of the
analysts on SportsCenter throughout the
NBA Finals legs joining us legs how are
you this morning
I'm doing great Dan it's good to talk to
you again my friend how are you man I'm
doing okay I got a couple of questions
including this one sent in from a member
of our audience
it's klay Thompson overrated or
underrated I definitely underrated no
question about it
you'll be great on that land okay these
are quick hitters he to me I think you
when you when you talk about basketball
and the importance of having five guys
play together and in the context of that
setting
you cannot overstate how important it is
to have a guy like klay Thompson that
can do what he does in a very short time
very decisively without needing the
basketball a ton but still be super
effective when he gets opportunities and
then the importance of his defense and
what that is allowed Steph Curry to be
defensively I mean the luxury of having
a guard that takes on every one of the
top point guard assignments defensively
and what that allows Steph Curry to then
be offensively because he's not nearly
as worried about foul trouble getting
fatigued getting worn out by probably
the toughest position in the league to
guard clay takes on that too so for me
he is he is still significantly
underrated but I'm looking at these
all-nba teams first of all why is the
media voting on something where there's
so much money attached to this Tim you
got guys who either could make 30 more
million or in the case of klay Thompson
it's gonna cost him perhaps 30 over 30
million dollars because he didn't make
one of the first three teams it
shouldn't be I think it's a joke if I
had been you know in the room when that
was decided like I was a player rep back
in 99 during the lockout and so you know
you listened a lot of these sensitive
topics when you're trying to get a CBA
done
there's no way as a player I would have
been in favor of this if I was involved
in it today because of what you just
said you got guys making decisions and
just look at the voting by the way take
a look at some of the guys that got
votes that you know you'll see like
others yeah we look at some of those
names on there and that and you're going
to tell me that you have
members voting for some of these people
for instance and I'm not gonna I'm not
taking a shot at Marvin Bagley because
he's I'm a big Marvin Bagley fan but
he's a rookie and made the all-rookie
team he deserved that yes somebody gave
him a third team all-nba vote so you've
got you guys there's a bunch of others
you could you could sift through that
list so you've got guys taking and
that's this that's the extent to which
they're casting their votes and that
you've got money tied into this it's a
big mistake it's awful for what the int
deal with the significance what it means
to the players I get another example
take a look at what it meant in the case
of Paul George when he was in Indiana
and he didn't get on that I don't
remember the exact level or he didn't
make third team or he needed to make a
higher level yeah whatever it was yeah
but he didn't get because of that he did
not get the super max capability with
his own team and why was that important
because look he might have left anyway
but I know this that Shrunk the
difference you know and financially for
him to it wasn't that big of a deal and
now he wanted to get out he ends up in
Oklahoma City it changes the trajectory
of your franchise in some ways you know
if they offer him a Super Max because he
makes that team who knows maybe that
extra 60 70 million bucks he could have
gotten could have been the difference he
resigns in Indiana so these are seismic
changes that can take place if guys
leave and the ability to pay them a
Super Max contract maybe that's enough
for guys to stay in certain situations
so I think it's a big mistake to have
media affect the money that goes into
guy's pockets that should be up to a
team what they want to offer a player
all right here's my other big problem
when these first second and third teams
come out okay we're now positioned las'
in the NBA when you say for the most
part that it's a position 'less sport
because I don't know what Steph is I
don't know what harden is I don't know
what LeBron is but and I always single
out Rudy Gobert and I don't even know
him and you know he's a wonderful player
he's not one of the top 15 players why
are we putting you gotta have a center
to forwards in two guards I want the 15
best players to be rewarded for all NBA
your thoughts yeah yeah I'm with you on
that I I think it's it's silly it's it's
and it's kind of done away with that at
the all-star game but they still keep it
for
this and I think it is silly because
you're right it is position list and it
should be based on the top 15 players
period rather than having a pigeonhole
that you have to fill certain slots
positionally now I will say this when
you look at the list I didn't have a big
problem with the 15 guys that were
selected when you start looking at that
next list of guys obviously to me clays
klay Thompson is a guy that it is I was
not six guards in the league I'm gonna
take ahead of play time okay but who do
I take out the legs am i taking out
Kemba I make taking out Russell
Westbrook because I got to take out
somebody Kyrie yeah I probably cover
Walker and and look I understand how
here's a lot of disord you know how this
recognition and how it's determined it's
very difficult to even get two guys on
any of these teams I think who had two
players Golden State in Oklahoma City
are they're the only two teams that had
two guys to get a third I mean it's
almost impossible so klay Thompson is
the guy that's because he's not top of
the food chain on that team he's going
to be hurt by that Kemba Walker is on
the top of the food chain in Charlotte
and he's a very good offensive player
but for me if you went around the league
and you you had every general manager in
the NBA select if they could have klay
Thompson her Kevin Walker it's probably
going to be maybe thirty to nothing in
favor of klay Thompson he's Tim Legler
from the mothership he'll be the analyst
on SportsCenter throughout the 2018-2019
NBA Finals here it feels like it's every
game game the game we're saying well
such and such as now the best player in
the game it was it long ago as a week
ago when the Greek freak was the best
player in the game now all of a sudden
Kawhi Leonard's the best player in the
game and then it was Steph Curry two
weeks ago who's the best player and then
prior to that it was Kevin during we
can't make up our damn mind is there a
best player in the game right now Tim oh
man that's a tough one you know I think
no I think it does kind of move around I
really I really should be so game to
game though or week to week not gaming
you know I think what's happening with
Yanis is like you know if you really
know the game I mean throughout the year
and I talked about him all season long
and he might win the MVP and I'm okay
with that but at the same time I was
pointing out there are significant
limitations to his game offensively the
problem is he's not exposed in the
regular season
when you you know when you get ready to
play the Bucs you didn't think about the
Bucs until literally that morning and so
now you got to try to put together this
you know pack the lane defense on him
you're not going to pull that off in a
one game regular season one off when you
didn't even discuss it until a film
session or a shoot around before the
game so you're not going to get the
level of commitment that the Toronto
Raptors are showing will you get to play
one opponent over and over and over and
you have a couple days even leading in
to the first game you're much more apt
to put together something like this and
they're the one team that's pulled this
off against him and exposed what he
can't do and that is beat you from
anywhere on the floor I mean we know
we've known all along if you watch him
you know okay he doesn't have a great
perimeter shot so but it doesn't matter
the regular season because he's still
effective because he's still able to get
where he wants to I call him a center
with a handle because that's really
where he scores he scores like a center
scorers he beats you up physically
inside of five feet he just comes at you
with a live handle long stride so it's a
little different way to play him the
Raptors have said we're gonna play a 1
to 2 zone basically two guys at the
elbows two at the block and we're gonna
force you into all kinds of traffic and
we're gonna take advantage of the fact
that you don't have an answer
offensively to shoot beyond us you don't
you're not a great passer off the
dribble that's why you're seeing all
these awkward turnovers when he gets
into the lane and now are you stumbling
and he's tripping and he's throwing the
ball you know into the crowd he's losing
it because he's so frustrated that he
can't beat you the way that he has all
season everybody else so those those
weaknesses were there all along
yeah and if you're smart you had to know
that and I think what this should do for
a lot of people if he does win the award
I think you have to now start to think
about what that really should mean
because for me
an MVP or super star in this league a
true superstar those are the guys that
can beat you from anywhere on the floor
as a scorer and if you look at the list
of guys that are going to finish in the
top five top ten in the NBA in the MVP
voting all of those guys can do it
including a guy like gol beat is a 71 to
80 player he could beat you from
anywhere Yanis has to add this to his
game if they lose this series I'm really
curious to see how much determination
the offseason - adding some other way to
beat you as a scorer if this is how he's
going to be played Kauai more likely to
stay or go if they go to the finals you
know I thought all along he had a great
chance to stay I you know look Dan
you're asking you know me and anybody
that would you'd ask this question to
try to figure out a guy that doesn't
really talk so I don't know how you come
up with any sort of indicator of what
where he's leaning but here's what I
thought from the time he got there this
is a city that he's going to really find
himself comfortable and he's also going
to find himself in a comfortable
situation from the standpoint he doesn't
have the media horde and the intense
scrutiny that he's going to get in a lot
of cities in the US where he is now we
have to answer questions every day be
accountable be responsible solve this
figure this out what's the problem he
doesn't want to deal with that and I
think he's in a good place for the city
that loves their team he's going to be
beloved and revered playing there
they're going to be good they're well
coached but he doesn't have to deal with
a lot of the things he's gonna have to
deal with he talked about going to
market like LA as the top guy now if he
goes to the shadow of another player
like LeBron it's different he'll take on
all that responsibility and and then
collective he's very comfortable in the
riding shotgun he doesn't seem like
that's what he wants I think he's a guy
that wants to be the top of the food
chain on his team Toronto seems like a
great fit for his personality so I think
for me it's been a 50/50 all along I
could be dead long he could this could
be a one-off where he's known all along
he's out of there after the season I
guess we're gonna find out on July 1st
yeah it's it's it's interesting the
Kawhi Leonard doesn't say anything we're
not sure what he's gonna do Kevin Durant
never stops talking and we don't know
what he's going to do you know they're
the two great mysteries there but those
two guys can change the balance of the
NBA
particularly if Durant would go east and
all of a sudden get Kyrie or Kemba
Walker to go to the next and if Kawhi
would somehow get talked into going to
the lake I just I can't
I know LeBrons out there on the
recruiting trail I just don't know what
that pitch is gonna be though legs do
you know and I don't and I don't know if
you're Kawhi Leonard why
exactly would you want to do that that's
the part that which that would make me
scratch my head like I understand Kyrie
Irving now wanting to go to New York
potentially to play with Kevin Durant
because it's clear now we know
Kyrie doesn't want any part of
leadership so he didn't like necessarily
not getting enough credit playing in the
shadow of LeBron and he thought he was
good enough to go take his own franchise
and take him to a special place he goes
to Boston it's pretty obvious by the way
he's conducted himself and what he has
said he wants no part of trying to lead
other players so for me it makes total
sense go to New York be back in the
shadow of a guy like Kevin Durant very
comfortable riding in in the in the
sidecar and and that's where his best
lane was as a player in Cleveland for
Kawhi I don't understand why you'd want
to do that after leaving San Antonio go
to Toronto if you lead this team to the
NBA Finals or who knows an NBA title why
would you then want to go play with
LeBron and live in his shadow to a
certain extent back out in the Western
Conference where you've got so many more
obstacles get back to that level that
that would be a real head-scratcher for
Durant I've kind of had the impression
going into the seasons based on the way
he looked at his body language at the
end of last year that he was going to
leave after this season I've thought it
all year never changed my mind on it I
think Kevin Durant is going to leave I
think his mind's been made up about that
for a long time he went out there did
what he needed to get rings on his
resume he did I think like that style
from afar but now I think he's looking
at it saying I'm never going to get
enough credit for what I accomplished
here as a player because they were
already so good when I got here and it's
always going to be Steph Curry's team so
now he's got another challenge he's
looking at and what could be better to
go in and taking this laughingstock
franchise in New York Knicks in a big
market like that and get them to
contention and relevancy I think he
relishes that challenge and I think
Kyrie is gonna join him there what do
you remember about winning the
three-point shooting contest back in
1996 I think the first thing that jumps
out at 12 to I would say number one I
was a guy because I was undrafted and I
went through the CBA and Europe
like this until some 10 days and cut and
sent back and I was starting to come
into my own and then I got to Washington
that year and I really you know found a
comfort zone so for me that was a lot
more than a shooting competition that
was validation as a player and getting
on a national stage and letting people
know and I was very confident going
there that weekend I was going to win
that thing
so that was the first thing it meant a
lot to me because of the road I had
traveled as a player the second thing it
meant was me and my daughter was born
just a week before my first child was
born so I remember going there and you
know basically doing that for her and
it's ironic cuz I remember doing the
interview after I want it and they give
you a check for 20 grand I don't know
what it is now was 20 grand at that time
and they asked me what I was going to do
with the money and I said it's going
into a college fund for my daughter and
don't you know Dan there's that thing
grew enough over the years my daughter
graduated last May from college and
she's now 2nd grade schoolteacher and
that check went a long way to pay for
her college education who did you who's
your biggest competition that year
yeah well Glen Rice was the defending
champion and so he was the guy that I
was kind of targeting Steve Kerr was in
that competition I think Dell curry was
in that Dennis Scott was pretty good
field I remember I remember being in the
locker room beforehand and cliff
Robinson was in it and cliff Robinson
said I was being kind of quiet had
headphones on I was just getting ready
going through mentally and I remember
him saying hey man yeah talking much
everybody feel a little tight and I
remember saying you know all the talking
in the world is not going to put the
ball in the basket and went out there
and I felt the balls I remember walking
out there the balls were brand-new they
were right on lock's slick you don't
talk yeah lick that glossy black plastic
he feeling him and I was getting a
little nervous because we're at the
Alamodome man it was it was a big venue
and I'm like okay these balls are kind
of slick your hands get sweaty it
doesn't slide off right once I started
to warm up I got into a really good
rhythm and warmups and I felt very
confident the other thing that had going
for me I got to shoot first which was
cool because I didn't have to wait a
long time after
warmups sitting there with all the
commercial breaks and all that stuff
I could go right into it and I got off
to a great start I think at 23 in the
first round and I was often flying and I
was very confident I was gonna win it
that's good stuff that's a great story
Congrats on your daughter graduating and
good to visit with you again legs
dad always great talking to you thank
you buddy that's a Tim Legler for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]